como la conservadora miconi barrett es
la nominada del presidente de trump para
la corte suprema de justicia de eeuu
hoy es un honor para mí y nominar a una
de las mentes legales más brillantes y
talentosas de nuestra nación para la
corte suprema- 76 women es una mujer de
logros incomparables intelecto imponente
credenciales excelentes y lealtad
inquebrantable a la constitución de carl
station
la juez amy cón y vert
el líder republicano del senado mitch
mcconnell confirmó que habrá un voto
para decidir sobre su eventual
confirmación a pocos días de las
elecciones el candidato demócrata a la
presidencia joe biden expresó su
oposición las decisiones de la corte
suprema- afectan nuestra vida diaria y
la constitución fue diseñada para dar a
los votantes una voz sobre quién toma
esas decisiones el senado no debería
actuar hasta que el pueblo
estadounidense escoja a su próximo
presidente y el próximo congreso los
estadounidenses merecen ser escuchados
barrett es conocida por sus
inclinaciones ultra conservadoras y por
ser una ferviente católica muchos temen
que su llegada al máximo tribunal sea
sinónimo de un duro golpe para los
derechos al aborto en el país otros
celebran esa posibilidad we are had
engañada women en él tenemos a otra
mujer en la corte suprema para ir en
contra de roe versus wade y dar más
decisiones de opciones a los estados me
apasiona mucho estoy muy emocionada de
ver lo que sucederá en el mundo mucho
está por cambiar con esta nueva nominada
si tienes una mujer que ha sido violada
o que cometió incesto y no quiere tener
el bebé para mí ese es su derecho dado
por dios
los demócratas denuncian que con barrett
también estaría en juego la continuidad
de la ley sanitaria conocida como
obamacare sin embargo al ser minoría en
el senado la bancada opositora no tiene
el poder para impedir la confirmación de
barrett que inclinaría la balanza del
máximo tribunal durante décadas